techos verdes o agricultura urbana.
Estamos familiarizados con la imagen de la izquierda que muestra
un jardín de un vecindario local (el South End, en Boston) .
Es lo que llamo hogar. Tengo una colmena en el patio trasero
y tal vez tenga un techo verde en el futuro,
cuando usemos más las zonas urbanas
donde hay muchos espacios de jardines.
Vean esta imagen por encima de la línea naranja del metro de Boston.
Intenten detectar la colmena. Está allí,
en el techo, justo en la esquina
y ha estado allí durante un par de años.
La forma en que opera actualmente la apicultura urbana
es que las colmenas están ocultas,
y no es porque tienen que estarlo.
Es solo porque la gente se incomoda con la idea
y es por eso que hoy quiero que traten de pensar en esto,
piensen en los beneficios de las abejas en las ciudades
y por qué son realmente tan maravillosas.
Déjenme darles un breve resumen de cómo funciona la polinización.
Sabemos que las flores, frutas y verduras,
incluso la alfalfa en el heno del ganado
que da las carnes que comemos, dependen de los polinizadores.
Vemos que las plantas tienen partes masculinas y femeninas,
y básicamente las plantas atraen a los polinizadores
por su néctar y en el proceso,
las abejas visitan algunas flores y recogen en el camino algo de polen,
o ese tipo de homólogo del esperma,
y luego viajan a otras flores y finalmente,
en este caso, se produce una manzana.
Se puede ver la orientación. El tallo está hacia abajo.
El extremo de la flor habrá caído para cuando la comamos,
pero eso es una descripción básica de cómo funciona la polinización.
Pensemos en la vida urbana, no hoy,
y no en el pasado, sino digamos en 100 años,
¿qué va a pasar? Tenemos grandes desafíos
estos días por la pérdida de hábitat. Tenemos cada vez más gente,
miles de millones de personas, y en 100 años, Dios sabe cuántas,
y poco espacio para todas ellas,
así que tenemos que cambiar la forma en que vemos las ciudades, y
al ver esta imagen a la izquierda de la ciudad de Nueva York hoy,
se aprecia lo gris y marrón que es.
En los techos, tenemos papel de alquitrán que devuelve el calor
a la atmósfera,
contribuyendo al cambio climático global, sin duda.
¿Qué pasaría en 100 años, si tenemos techos verdes
en todas partes y jardines y creamos nuestros propios cultivos
justo en las ciudades? Ahorraríamos los costos del transporte,
tendríamos una dieta saludable a un menor costo, y también educaríamos
y crearíamos nuevos puestos de trabajo nivel local.
Necesitamos abejas para el futuro de nuestras ciudades y la vida urbana.
Aquí hay algunos datos que hemos recogido a través de nuestra empresa
con «Best Bees» [las mejores abejas], donde entregamos, instalamos y administramos
colmenas de abejas para quien las quiera,
en la ciudad, en el campo, y presentamos las abejas
y la idea de la apicultura en su propio patio o azotea
o para el caso, en el escape de incendios,
y mostramos lo fácil y posible que es.
Hay una tendencia contraria al sentido común que notamos
en estos números. Así que analicemos la primera medida aquí,
la supervivencia en el invierno.
Esto ha sido un gran problema durante muchos años,
básicamente desde finales de los años 80, cuando llegó el ácaro varroa
y trajo consigo diferentes virus, bacterias
y enfermedades fúngicas.
El éxito en el invierno es difícil,
y allí es cuando se pierden la mayoría de las colonias,
y hemos constatado que en las ciudades, las abejas sobreviven
mejor que en el campo.
Un poco contradictorio, ¿verdad?
Pensamos, ¡oh!, abejas, campo, agricultura,
pero eso no lo que las abejas están mostrando.
A las abejas les gusta la ciudad. (Risas)
Además, también producen más miel.
La miel urbana es deliciosa.
Las abejas en Boston en la azotea del Hotel Seaport,
donde tenemos cientos de miles de abejas
que lo sobrevuelan en este momento,
aunque estoy seguro de que ninguno de ustedes lo ha notado al pasar por allí,
van a todos los jardines comunitarios locales
y producen miel deliciosa y saludable
que solo sabe a las flores de nuestra ciudad.
Por lo tanto, el rendimiento de las colmenas urbanas, en términos de producción de miel,
es mayor, así como la supervivencia en invierno,
en comparación con las zonas rurales.
Una vez más, un poco contradictorio.
Si miramos, históricamente, la cronología
de salud de la abeja, nos remontamos al año 950, cuando
hubo una gran mortandad de las abejas en Irlanda.
Así que los problemas de las abejas hoy no son necesariamente
algo nuevo. Ha estado ocurriendo
desde hace más de mil años,
pero no nos damos cuenta de estos problemas en las ciudades.
Quiero animarlos a pensar en algo:
la idea de una isla urbana.
Piensen que tal vez la temperatura es más cálida en la ciudad.
¿Por qué las abejas están mejor en la ciudad?
Esta es una gran pregunta para ayudarnos a entender
por qué las abejas deben estar en la ciudad.
Quizás allí hay más polen.
Los trenes que llegan a centros urbanos, pueden
traer polen con ellos, polen muy liviano,
y este es solo un gran supermercado en la ciudad.
Una gran cantidad de tilos viven a lo largo de las vías del tren.
Tal vez en las ciudades haya menos pesticidas
que en las zonas rurales.
Tal vez haya otras cosas en las que simplemente no hemos pensando todavía,
pero esta es una idea, las islas urbanas.
El síndrome de colapso de la colonia no es lo único
que afecta a las abejas. Las abejas se están muriendo,
y ese es un gran reto para nuestro tiempo.
Lo que se ve aquí es un mapa del mundo
y hacemos un seguimiento de la propagación del ácaro varroa.
Este ácaro cambió las reglas del juego
en la apicultura y se puede ver, en la parte superior derecha,
que los años están cambiando, llegamos a tiempos modernos
y se puede ver la propagación del ácaro varroa
desde comienzos del siglo XX hasta ahora.
En 1968, llegó a la mayor parte de Asia,
en 1971, se extendió a Europa y América del Sur,
y luego, cuando llegamos a la década de 1980,
y específicamente a 1987, finalmente llegó
a América del Norte y a los Estados Unidos,
y las reglas del juego cambiaron
para las abejas en los Estados Unidos.
Muchos de nosotros recordaremos que en nuestra infancia,
tal vez sufrimos una picadura de abeja o vimos abejas en las flores.
Piensen en los niños de hoy. Su infancia es un poco diferente.
No experimentan eso.
Las abejas ya no están alrededor.
Necesitamos a las abejas, pero están desapareciendo y esto es un gran problema.
¿Qué podemos hacer?
Me dedico a la investigación de abejas melíferas.
Obtuve mi doctorado en el estudio de la salud de las abejas melíferas.
Empecé a estudiar estas abejas en el 2005.
En el 2006, las abejas comenzaron a desaparecer,
y de repente este chico nerd
que iba a la escuela a estudiar insectos —(Risas)—
se convirtió en alguien muy relevante en el mundo.
Y así resultó ser.
Así que mi investigación se centra en formas de hacer que las abejas sean más saludables,
y no en la investigación de lo que está matando a las abejas, per se.
No soy uno de los muchos investigadores alrededor del mundo
que examinan los efectos de pesticidas o enfermedades
o la pérdida del hábitat y la malnutrición en las abejas.
Estamos buscando maneras de hacer que las abejas sean más saludables
a través de vacunas y yogur, como probióticos,
y otros tipos de terapias que puedan ser suministradas a las abejas por vía oral,
y este proceso es tan fácil que incluso un niño de 7 años puede hacerlo.
Solo hay que mezclar un poco de polen, azúcar y agua,
y cualquier ingrediente activo que se desee agregar
y se le da directamente a las abejas. Sin productos químicos,
solo refuerzos inmunitarios.
Pensamos en nuestra propia salud de forma prospectiva.
Hacemos ejercicio, comemos de manera saludable, tomamos vitaminas.
¿Por qué no pensamos en las abejas de esa misma forma?
Llevarlas a las zonas donde están prosperando
y tratar de mejorar su salud antes de que se enfermen.
Pasé muchos años de mi posgrado tratando de pinchar abejas y hacer vacunas
con agujas. (Risas) Años,
años en la mesa de trabajo, «Oh, Dios mío, son las 3 a.m.
y todavía estoy inyectando abejas». (Risas)
Luego un día dije: «¿por qué no hacemos simplemente una vacuna oral?»
Es como, «¡uf!», así que eso es lo que hacemos. (Risas)
Quisiera compartir con ustedes algunas imágenes de colmenas urbanas,
porque pueden ser cualquier cosa.
Quiero decir, realmente abran su mente con esto.
Pueden pintar las colmenas para que hagan juego con sus casas.
Pueden ocultar una colmena dentro de sus hogares.
Aquí hay tres colmenas en la azotea
del hotel Fairmont Copley Plaza,
y son hermosas. Es decir, hacen juego con
el nuevo color del interior de sus habitaciones para hacer
algún tipo de madera teñida de azul para sus sábanas.
Estas abejas son buenísimas y también van a usar
las hierbas que crecen en el jardín.
Eso es lo que los chefs van a usar para cocinar,
y la miel —hacen eventos en vivo—
usarán esa miel en sus bares.
La miel es un gran sustituto nutricional del azúcar tradicional
porque contiene diferentes tipos de azúcar.
También tenemos un proyecto de colmenas para las aulas,
en el que —es una empresa sin fines de lucro—
difundimos la idea alrededor del mundo para que sepan cómo
llevar colmenas de abejas a las aulas
o en el entorno de un museo, detrás de un vidrio,
y usarlas como una herramienta educativa.
Esta colmena que ven aquí ha estado
en la escuela secundaria Fenway desde hace muchos años.
Las abejas vuelan directo a los jardines del parque Fenway.
Nadie lo nota. Si no eres una flor,
estas abejas no se preocupan por ti. (Risas)
No lo hacen. Ellas dirían:
«Permiso, estoy volando por aquí». (Risas)
Aquí hay algunas otras imágenes que cuentan una parte de la historia
que hizo que la apicultura urbana fuese excelente.
En Nueva York, la apicultura fue ilegal hasta el 2010.
Ese es un gran problema, porque ¿cómo se van a polinizar
los jardines y cultivos localmente? ¿Con las manos?
A nivel local en Boston, hay una gran empresa llamada
«Green City Growers» [Cultivadores de ciudades verdes], y ellos van
y polinizan sus cultivos de zapallos a mano con hisopos,
y si no lo hacen dentro de un periodo de tres días, no hay ningún fruto.
Sus clientes no están satisfechos, y hay gente que pasa hambre.
Esto es importante.
Tenemos también algunas imágenes de la miel de Brooklyn.
Esto fue un misterio en el New York Times
porque la miel era muy roja y hasta
Intervino el departamento de medicina forense de Nueva York
y llevó a cabo experimentos para constatar
que la coloración roja provenía
de una fábrica de cerezas al marrasquino en esa misma calle. (Risas)
Así que pueden adaptar su miel para que tenga el sabor que deseen
plantando flores agradables para las abejas.
París ha sido un excelente modelo para la apicultura urbana.
Desde hace muchos años, han tenido colmenas en la azotea
de la casa de la ópera y eso hizo que la gente comenzara a pensar:
«¡Guau!, podemos hacerlo, y deberíamos hacerlo».
También en Londres y en Europa a través de la Unión,
están muy avanzados en el uso de azoteas verdes
y la integración de colmenas,
y les voy a mostrar una nota final aquí.
Me gustaría animarlos a abrir su mente.
¿Qué pueden hacer para salvar o ayudar a las abejas
o para que el futuro de las ciudades sea sostenible?
Bueno, realmente, solo cambien su perspectiva.
Traten de entender que las abejas son muy importantes.
Una abeja no va a picarles si la miran.
La abeja muere. Las abejas mueren cuando pican,
así que ellas tampoco quieren picarlos. (Risas)
No es nada para entrar en pánico. Están por toda la ciudad.
Pueden incluso tener sus propias colmenas si lo desean;
hay grandes recursos disponibles,
hasta hay empresas que ayudan a establecerlas y brindan tutoría.
Y es importante para el sistema educativo mundial
que los estudiantes aprendan sobre la agricultura en todo el mundo
como esta niña a la que, una vez más, ni siquiera la están picando.
Gracias. (Aplausos)